allez on ouvre la page politique à
présent avec la loi de vigilance
sanitaire qui arrive au sénat à partir
d'aujourd'hui hier le ministre de la
santé a été auditionné par les sénateurs
dans le cadre de ce projet de loi
vigilance sanitaire on va retrouver tout
de suite notre reporter guillemin rosie
devant le palais du luxembourg à paris
[Musique]
bonjour lui main vous êtes donc devant
le sénat et qu'est ce qui est ressorti
de cette audition du ministre de la
santé hier
et bien bonjour magali bien déjà que
l'exécutif est loin de faire l'unanimité
au sénat elle est loin d'être en terrain
conquis ici ce sont les républicains qui
règne en maître et pas la majorité
présidentielle ce qui fait que les
sénateurs ont un petit peu cuisine et le
ministre de la santé l'objet de cette
audition parlementaire c'était bien le
projet de loi vigilance sanitaire et les
élus n'ont pas hésité à remettre en
doute l'efficacité du paso san et
sanitaire à commencer par le sénateur
philippe bach à porter sur le texte car
s'il est vrai qu'il est difficile de
contester l'efficacité de cette mesure
sur l'accélération de la campagne de
vaccination en revanche le conseil
scientifique lui-même début octobre au
début du mois disait qu'il était déclaré
qu'il était difficile de mettre en
évidence le rôle de cette mesure sur la
protection des individus donc la
question de la légitimité se pose un du
maintien ou non de ce fameux pas
sanitaire cependant pas pour olivier
vers aurait coûté
imaginez que vous alliez des voitures
automatiques dont on vous dit ce
qu'elles sont parfaitement sûrs et ne
produisent plus d' accidents de la route
est ce que pour autant dès les premiers
mois vous allez retirer la ceinture
obligatoire
on n'a pas suffisamment de recul à ce
stade pour pouvoir nous priver d'un
outil qui est fonctionnel et qui est
bien acceptée par les gens voilà une
phrase qui a fortement déplu à florian
philippot l'une des principales figures
politiques de l'opposition passe
sanitaires écoutez
on n'a pas assez de recul pour pouvoir
s'en priver différents au sénat cynique
verront inverse la charge de la preuve
il faudrait démontrer qu'on ne peut s'en
passer alors qu'évidemment c'est à lui
de prouver que c'est utile fourberie de
kovy liste alors le leader des patriotes
qui a lancé un appel à manifester
aujourd'hui 17h devant le sénat
oui et la vaccination des soignants a
également été évoquer guillemin par le
ministre hier ainsi qu'une éventuelle
troisième dose
oui tout à fait magali 1 vous n'êtes pas
sans savoir que depuis le 15 octobre
dernier les soignants ont l'obligation
de présenter un schéma vaccinal complet
s'ils veulent continuer à poursuivre
leur lors la halle à exercer leur
profession cela concerne évidemment
beaucoup beaucoup de monde il s'agit des
salariés des hôpitaux publics des
cliniques des maisons de retraite les
aides à domicile les pompiers les
ambulanciers les soignants libéral bref
beaucoup de monde près de trois millions
de personnes dont certaines ont été
hésitants très réticente à se faire
vacciner mais visiblement la menace de
la suspension sans salaire semble avoir
eu l'effet escompté selon le ministre
les deux tiers des soignants suspendus
sont revenus au travail une fois
vacciner on est donc un taux de
couverture vaccinale des salariés des
établissements sanitaires et médico
sociaux qui est extrêmement élevé et un
taux de suspension et de démission qui
est extrêmement faible voilà elle se
chiffre au 20 octobre dernier c'était
encore près de 8000 soignants qui
étaient toujours suspendus des soignants
qui peuvent depuis le 5 octobre dernier
recevoir une troisième dose de vaccin
mais on ne sait toujours pas quand ni
même si cette troisième dose deviendra
obligatoire que ce soit pour les
soignants ont pour l'ensemble de la
population à cette question olivier
verrey hier en audition n'a pas répondu
l'attend encore plus d'éléments de la
part de la haute autorité de santé ou du
conseil scientifique que le ministre de
la santé qui à titre personnel lui c'est
bien fait vacciner il s'est fait
injecter une troisième dose de vaccin
pfizer hier après midi une façon pour
lui d'envoyer un signal pour inciter à
la vaccination